my theory of evolution is that darwin
was adopted
i got a new dog he's a paranoid
retriever
he brings back everything because he's
not sure what i throw
my uncle was a clown for ringling
brother circus
and when he died all his friends went to
the funeral in one car
so i get out of the bed i figured i'd go
for a walk she said how long you gonna
be going i said the whole time
and i was thinking about the new phone
that i bought and the first thing i did
was push redial
phone had a nervous breakdown
whenever i think about the past it just
brings back so many memories
i remember the day the candle shop
burned down
everybody just stood around and sang
happy birthday
and then we saw a sign next mile one
mile
one time right in the middle of a job
interview i took out a book and i
started reading
the guy said what the hell are you doing
i said let me ask you one question
if you were in a vehicle and you were
traveling at the speed of light
and then you turned your lights on
would they do anything
he said i don't know i said forget it
then i don't want to work for you
[Applause]
i remember when i was a fetus i used to
sneak out at night when my mother was
sleeping
[Applause]
i thought to myself you know now's the
time i should start stealing some stuff
since i don't have any fingerprints
i bought some powdered water but i don't
know what to add
sponges grow in the ocean
that kills me i wonder how much deeper
the ocean would be if that didn't happen
[Music]
there's a fine line between fishing and
just standing on the shore like an idiot
i can levitate birds but nobody cares
it's a good thing there's gravity
otherwise when birds die they just stay
right up there
hunters would be all confused
thinking about my grandfather and how he
had a special rocking chair built that
would lean forward rather than backwards
so he could fake
interest in any conversation
[Applause]
we took a lie detector test no i didn't
i remember when i was seven my
grandmother said stephen come over here
and i said what do you mean
she said you know you're over there now
come over here
i said all right and she said here's ten
dolls and don't tell your mother that
i'm giving this to you
and i said it'll cost you more than that
[Applause]
i've never seen electricity that's why i
don't pay for it
all right right on the bill sorry i
haven't seen it all months
[Applause]
i bought this thing from my car you put
it on your car
it sends out this little noise when you
drive through the woods deer won't run
in front of your car
i installed it backwards by accident
driving down the street with a herd of
deer chasing me
i'm going to court next week i have been
selected for jury duty
[Music]
it's kind of an insane case six thousand
ants dressed up as rice and robbed a
chinese restaurant
i don't think they did it
i know a few of them and they wouldn't
do anything like that
so i was laying in bed with my
girlfriend reading the second hand diary
that i bought
i don't remember this she said let me
ask you a question i said what and she
said if you could know how and when you
were gonna die would you want to know
and i said no and she said forget it
then
left the store and went down the street
to my bus my bus came and i get on
started walking toward the back sat down
beside this beautiful blonde
chinese girl
i said hello and she said hello i said
isn't an amazing day
she said yes it is i guess i said what
do you mean you guess
she said well things haven't been going
too well for me lately
i said like what she said i can't tell
you i don't even know you
and i said yeah but sometimes it's good
to tell your problems to an absolute
total stranger on a bus
she said well i've just come back from
my analyst and he's still unable to help
me
i said what's the problem she paused and
said
i'm a nymphomaniac and i only get turned
on by jewish cowboys
then she said by the way my name is
diane and i said hello diane i'm bucky
goldstein
[Applause]
[Music]
you